[Musik]
politik und landwirtschaft haben sich
voneinander entfremdet diesen befund
hört man in letzter zeit immer wieder
bauern fühlen sich häufig missverstanden
und als umweltsünder verunglimpft neue
gesetze und eu vorgaben machen ihnen das
leben genauso schwer wie billig preise
für fleisch und milch viele unter ihnen
leiden auch darunter zu wenig
gesellschaftliche anerkennung zu
erhalten florian klenk chefredakteur der
österreichischen wochenzeitung der
falter kennt sich mit diesem problem
inzwischen gut aus erst verteidigte er
im fernsehen die schadensersatzklage
gegen einen baum dessen für eine frau
getötet hatten dann wurde er von einem
landwirt auf facebook verspottet und zu
einem praktikum auf dessen hof
eingeladen
ergebnis dieses geplänkels ist eine
spektakuläre spendenaktion und ein buch
namens bauer und bobo untertitel wie aus
wut freundschaft wurde mein name ist
khan schwanke ich bin in unserem filtern
für die neuen sachbücher zuständig unter
florian klenk im heutigen faz bücher
podcast begrüßen also erklingt hallo
vielleicht rekapitulieren wir noch
einmal was ihrem praktikum auf dem hof
von christian bachner so heißt der bauer
der sie online neun minuten lang
beschimpft hat alles vorausging
ausgangspunkt der ganzen ereigniskette
war der tod einer deutschen touristin in
österreich wie kam es dazu und was
passierte dann der ausgangspunkt war
eine deutsche touristin die über eine
alm gewandert ist mit ihrem hund und ich
dass dieses öffentlichen weg der können
ausschließt dass durchgeführt hat von
einer who paktiert worden eine mutterkuh
muss man dazu sagen das ende der kleines
kalb hatte weltweit an bei der kuh die
milch getrunken hat und die kuh
herzliche frau getötet und
die
hinterbliebenen die kinder aber auch der
wwf deutschland haben daraufhin den
bauern verklagt zivilrechtlich nicht
strafe ich gehe es um eine entschädigung
zu bekommen damit dass trauer schmerz
die gelder aber vor allem auch im winter
als waisenkind das von der regierung ist
bauern letztlich bezahlt wird und das
gericht dass ich glaube es gegen
innsbruck hat die so soll er recht
gegeben oder gesagt diese bauer hätte
die gruppe verfahren müssen er hätte
einen elektrozaun spanien können oder
den charakter machen müssen weil er
wusste dass diese gefährlicher deco hat
auch schon vorher eine touristin
attackiert und auch am selben tag sogar
schon einmal eine touristen attackiert
die nur überlebte weil sie einen
rucksack der iraner dieser kuh in diesem
rucksack stecken geblieben sind und das
hat einen riesigen aufschrei geführt in
österreich ein aufschrei der bis zu
bundeskanzler sebastian kohls die für
tapie kammer verdreht und der
landwirtschaftskammer die zucht kann man
sogar die grünen eigentlich ist kantiger
dieses mittel dazu führen werden dass
die bauern in zukunft eher ein
wirtschafts mehr betragen alte
kulturtechnik nämlich die weite
landschaft in den hochalmen
möglicherweise gefährdet ich habe
gelesen und
studierter jurist gelesen und ich fand
das mittel thron vernünftig und habe mir
gedacht wenn der bau finden kündigt
ordentlich aufpasst und das einen
öffentlichen weg eine touristin mit
einem genannten und geht dann so
liquidierung der überzahl und das
berliner unglaublichen shitstorm
ausgelöst sich in einer
fernsehdiskussion als er muss tv besitzt
der längliche sender geschafft habe und
was hat dazu geführt dass christen
bachler den ich vorher nicht kannten an
körpergewicht in tirol rücken für
passiert ist sondern in der steiermark
dass dieser kisten bachler sie heben
gemüse gefüllt hat sich mit seiner wohl
habe im winter auf einen schweinestall
probe zu stellen sein iphone auf sich
gerichtet und dann eine minutenlange
wutrede auch nicht abgelassen hat dass
diese arrogante pinkl auf der stadt
dieser potro der budo abo emea der
vermieter jahren hat aber immer geredet
der sollte einmal zu bekommen und ein
praktikum machen damit ein schweinegeld
zu stehen diese wutrede hat fast zehn
minuten gedauert was hat er ihnen im
detail alles vorgehalten bachler hat
zwei dinge gemacht die erste mal
sozusagen eine erklärung gemacht warum
die bauern auf den almen die kühe nicht
so bewachen können bis das gericht jeden
berge sagte die körper und wasser
gewissen auch ähnliche wege kreuzen
können und die touristen müssen einfach
er muss klar sein dass dies nichts
eine gefahr so muss man etwa eine fläche
die kuh kommt besonders viele touristen
obwohl sie auch später eigentliches
mietschulden attestiert hatte den hund
nicht los gekettet hat sondern deren an
einem karabiner ich habe selber auch
nicht die mussten um zusammen weg laufen
lässt er die kunst den menschen mit dem
104 und er hatte in lang ausgeführt
verhinderung nämlich das bedauern ohne
wie es schon so viel klagen konfrontiert
sind keine touristen die da über diese
heilen gehen und dass die allman
eigentlich ist ja sonst nicht so viel
dass geräte zu bauen sind wo eigentlich
die touristen besonders die
baskets die antipathie vater nichts
verloren haben ist der erste der zweite
teil der hat mich dann aber irgendwie
berührt und herausgefordert der
lautesten gemeint hat naja du arroganter
steht die überprüfung halter du hast
eigentlich von der freundlichen
geschehnisse keller aber du hast mir
selbst noch nie existenzangst gehabt du
hast keine ahnung wie es uns da oben in
den bergen unterwegs ein moment wo sie
gedacht habt verflucht nochmal habe
recht und ich habe mir die frage
gestellt
warum hat er eine band an und ich den
ganzen tag stehen jeden tag wieder auf
und geben schlafen und arbeiten zu ihr
warum dass jemand nach sicherungen geben
sollte das so viel unterstützung geben
sollte ich dachte immer die ist dafür da
dass eben auch die kleinen betriebe
überleben für einen werktag ist warum
spricht er von existenzangst befragen
die kleine fan war nicht ich habe von
der bäuerlichen gesellschaftsform aber
da habe ich mir die frage gestellt was
ist das eigentlich die bäuerliche
gesellschaft wo
kommt die er was lebt eine stadt und im
speckgürtel und man kennt alle diese
industrialisierten kleinstädte vorne vor
dem hässlichen allerlei geplante
tankstellen und auto verloren und wurde
die ortskerne sterben aber was ist eine
bäuerliche gesellschaft muss vom platz
und das hat mich bekommen zu
interessieren und irgendwie auch mehr
honig ums maul geschmiert sagt
eigentlich hätte ja meine arbeit und
werde jetzt habe ich mir gedacht nachdem
sich das video scharf 200.000 menschen
eingeschaltet werde ich muss dieses
angebot eines praktikums annehmen nicht
nur als journalistin im politisch
interessant sind sondern eigentlich auch
ein bisschen beruhigen weil mehr da
schon irgendwie in den kopf geschossen
ist das eigentlich auch interne
bäuerliche vergangenheit habe mich
persönlich aber mein vater aus einem
bauerndorf gekommen es gibt von dem er
immer wieder mal so ein bisschen
erzählte dass ich aber eigentlich
verstanden habe was ein deutliches und
dieses ganze bäuerlichen dörfern
eigentlich gar nicht mehr gibt und die
ich mir die frage gestellt warum
eigentlich sie haben dann das angebot
angenommen wie lange haben sie ihn
begleitet auf der alm ja ich war
ungefähr drei tage ebenso das verlange
ich habe dann noch ein zweites mal
besucht aber auf die in gefahr also man
muss ich das bekommen jetzt mehr
vorstellen besieg dich hart gearbeitet
hat sondern ich habe mich eigentlich
schon durch seine welt zu entführen
lassen es hat mir sehr genau anschauen
wie er bachler arbeitet und wer bastelt
das was er nicht schon eine sehr
bemerkenswerte
erfahrung weil ich da von den menschen
getroffen gehen mit dem bach hatte ein
großer erklärt er anhand funktionen
naturbeobachtungen anhand von sehr sehr
konzentrierten beschreibungen feines vom
kosmos seines teaminternen tennis
schwester alternative
eines ökosystems runkelrübe sehr
wichtige grundsätzliche politische frage
gestellt hat mein lieblingsbeispiel war
immer die geschichte der zwerg schlamm
schlecker das war ganz am anfang als ich
ihn getroffen habe ich bin dann in zug
gefahren und es nur tal dagegen dass
bayern lag nun befindest teil des
ausschusses erhole in den beginnt merkel
und als ich angekommen bin mit
bezahlbares seine dieselloks die dafür
so ein bisschen abgeräumt dies und da
hinein vergehen ist es schöner tag
empfängt dann nicht und sagt man muss
jetzt ein
mediziner foto somit spielen heißt das
ist der blaue tektur und die conclusio
suchst du design und ja sagt zu mir naja
ich brauchte aber das schüttet weniger
wert ist hinter müssen behandelt werden
da die haben den leber eg und woher
haben die mittel in eckiger das leben
cdl sehen die zwerg schlamms nächste
schlappe wenn sie trinken kann sich
sogar um die werkstätten der verkehr ja
die zwerg slum schnecken wir zu ihr in
den tälern gelebt und dass die
klimaerwärmung geht sie immer höheren
daraufhin die bergregionen und dort gibt
es immer weniger wasser und bier mehr zu
sitzen wir ja und viele verunreinigungen
in diesem pfützen ist mit werk schlamm
schnecke und wie man die zwischen der
gefliesten hinten fehlt macht den leb-
und anleger gemacht die leber kaputt und
dadurch klingen die tiere schaden und um
sterben und da haben sich mit dem klose
mit dem behandlungspause mit dem hat
aber zur folge dass die
geschlagen die den inka ausscheiden
damit kontaminiert sind von dieser
medizin dass die insekten die tiefen
kuhfladen eigentlich zulegen sollten tot
umfallen und die käfer und daher
eigentlich der einbilden nicht mehr
gedüngt und das habe ich entdeckt an
aktive scannen lieber englisch und der
zwerg schlamm schnecke wie eine
klimatische veränderung da oben den
bergen auf einmal das ganze ökosystem
kanada wird nicht riesengroß aber doch
aber doch so dass sehr bemerkenswert war
und solche geschichten hat er eine nach
der anderen erzählt die eigentlich sehr
exemplarisch uns ja täglich geschrieben
habe war es darum geht hatte den bergen
passiert und das betraf nicht nur den
klimawandel sondern auch die
fleischindustrie die art und weise wie
bauern gefördert werden und eine
obduktion wird ihre förderungen auch
verlieren aufgrund durch das
bürokratische
schikanen fehlentscheidungen und er hat
doch erzählt wie wir die finanzierung
angriff waren die bayern hatten sondern
geld kommen und das hat mich immer mehr
zum geschirr begonnen und dann habe ich
mir ja doch in der reportage geschrieben
und weiter so haben wir uns den krieg
erklärt wir kommen gleich noch auf die
auf die fleischindustrie und auf die
großen zusammenhänge die den bauern
probleme bereiten aber vielleicht gehen
wir noch mal einen schritt zurück wie
muss man sich diesen hof eigentlich
vorstellen also wie viele tiere hat herr
bachler wie groß ist die fläche die ihm
zur verfügung steht und wie es so der
gesamteindruck wenn man da ankommt
in der steiermark das ist ein ziemliches
bundes landes und
das ist ein hoch wie man ihn eigentlich
ausbildung als unserer generation
kinderbücher kennen verlaufen wie puten
herum und wer hat ungefähr 20 25 rinder
stehen das interessante ist das war aber
auch sehr viele tierarten hat die man
auf normalen leben nicht zählt zum
beispiel jack swigert einer online
plattform will haben in das ich so liebe
ich mein ja gekauft weil er nämlich
kinder braucht die ganz hoch oben in den
bergen besonders schlechte gras wachsen
die rasenspieler die früher die pferde
und schafe gefressen haben und sollte
für ein chef verbots gibt oder des
schächtens sehr stark eingeschränkt
wurde dass man genau so lohnt es sich
nicht mehr schafe zu halten und dadurch
hat sich diese raten schmiede
ausgebreitet und die schafe haben das
nicht mehr gefressen und kartenspiele
macht über die einem text die woche zu
tun und das ist genau dieses recht wenn
die zumindest aber und die jagd auf den
vorteil dass im winter draußen leben
können er braucht auch keine stelle
bauen sich im winter die beheizten muss
und damit braucht keine kritiker mehr
von der reifenbreite diese stelle
finanzieren und zu sagt fleischhauer
vermarkten das ist ein edleres oder ein
ungewöhnliches und die jaxx die die
haben sich mittlerweile verstärkter
informiert und trost aber auch immer
wieder bilder so das war mal so eine
interessante dinge was du das beiseite
dass er bekannte dass waren diskutierten
alpen schweine gelten schweine das sind
so kleine schwarze steine die er
entdeckt hat in südtirol eine schwere
erste die nach dem ersten weltkrieg zu
boden wurde weil viel zu langsam
gewachsen wurde und die bevölkerung
nicht ernähren konnte die er sehr
angebracht war auch das leben in den
alpen bei dem die molke gesorgt und die
konnten auch im bilde gartenleben ihre
füße kommt noch im schnee gut überleben
und diese alle schweine züchtet er dort
und die anzusagen also braucht da auch
keine maschinen fliegen für ziele die
antwort herum wird erst wenn immer sagt
sonne die schnauze flug und tedi
dünger sprühen gehen sie dann gleich
ausgewiesen und da braucht würde ich
nicht viel kümmern die leben draußen
ansicht werden die erde ein und leben
dort mit dem mann geliebt schweinemäster
wollschweine die partie in der monarchie
hat noch millionen haft den gesprächen
im tank österreich gehalten hat die eben
draußen leben konnte und das gegenteil
von dem schweine sind von denen wir uns
heute werden ist dieses klassische
großer schwer einiges sehr oft nur im
feuchten boden eingedrungen lebt und
keine sonne sieht dass man in dänemark
hat er dann erzählt sogar um zu ändern
also der rotor mit sonnencreme
eingeschmiert werden muss indem man kurz
in die luft in der diskussion und
pflegen wir den ganzen tag nur mit soja
als brasilianischen regenwälder werden
damit sie möglichst fit antreten wenn
ebendiese dir ist ja schnell
positionieren müssen wenn du mir einen
kilopreis haben von ungefähr einem euro
1 euro gegen den patagonischen einem
tier und je mehr ich diesen roth
angeschaut hatte faszinierte war ja
eigentlich von diesem von diesen
mikrokosmos und habe aber noch nicht
geahnt oder ahnen können kreative der
partie die welt eigentlich kurz vor dem
abgrund gestanden
wie sieht denn eigentlich so ein ganz
normaler arbeitstag von christian
bachner aus wann steht der aufwand geht
ins bett und was passiert alles
dazwischen sowie die meisten bauen sehr
früh auf und ab dann je nach jahreszeit
bieten verschiedene bauliche tätigkeit
muss machte er
verbringt im sommer sehr viel zeit auf
dem anwender sagt der besuch dort ich
sage jetzt besuchte er schaut nach einem
kühlen r schaut die kühe abgestürzt hin
und für gesund sind ob sie sich verletzt
haben umfeld hätten ihre kinder füttert
sie dort mit nahrungsmitteln er findet
seine schweine er hat seine linie guten
seine gänse die also
gepflegt werden wurde schließen muss
also bei rund herum
ist nicht so brauchbar
aufgeräumter als auf den ersten blick
auf den ersten blick fast glauben dass
sie fit werden
messi im
europäischen mächte sabine sehr naturnah
haben die den hof zu bewirtschaften hat
zb indem rinderstall lässt er immer
wieder regen was zu stehen weil die
indischen regel lastet dann in den
pfützen wir fliegen ihre warten hinein
legen was wiederum die schweine gerne
treffen und er unglücklich er war mit
dem traktor wieder bewiesen auch dafür
bekannt aber fehlt wie sehr auch die
biobauern für das insekten sterben
verantwortlich sind welche die lieferung
zu finden weil sie die werke haben die
das grasen reise brechen die
die insekten kaum noch möglich das zu
erleben er hat sehr beeindruckend für
mich auch immer wieder sehr viel gefehlt
und ich arbeite für die bergrettung muss
man wieder ausrücken werden wanderer
abstürzen oder skifahrer verschwiegen
sind und erlebt dort zur miete alleine
zumindest eine frage habt und das ist
auch eine interessante beobachtung weil
das natürlich
eine entwicklung ist wie viele bauern
haben wenn ich die vereinsamung noch
seine generation die die als agent war
hat er dort noch gelebt mit seinen
geschwistern seinen ämtern und den
großeltern ist die ganze familie hat
sich im hof bewirtschaftet mittlerweile
ist er dort alleine los die mit über 60
jahre alt mindestens gleich gut mit aber
bemerkt er mit allein sieht auch eine
situation der überforderung sehr oft zu
beobachten zu der auch empfiehlt hat die
aufbauende sehr verschieden sind weil
sie oft auch noch die schulden der
vorgänger abtragen müssen oder die
eltern in einem ausgedinge
bezahlen müssen so kommt es dass er zu
seiner leiste dies mit der bitte arbeit
auf dem hof ferne muss jemand ein bauer
alleine diese arbeit schultern und hatte
auch immer so mit dem menschlichen
darüber unterhalten kann und da bachler
zwei auswege die sich gesucht das
einiger dafür sich sie auftrag bekannten
an den hof holt auch auf deutschland
interessanterweise landwirtschafts
studenten und mehr medizinstudenten oder
leute die einfach bearbeiten wollen und
er hat begonnen etwas zumuten dass er
den traktor des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert in motion video hat begonnen
ist eine eigene community aufzubauen um
dieses einen rückkanal der
jedes mal tausende lex produziert nicht
nur bilder zu kosten von danny tieren
die er dort züchtet und dem leben am
land sondern er war immer wieder auch
politische statement kunst reden kurz
erklärungen und er betreibt die wir
diese social media auch einen eigenen
workshop mehr fleisch per post
zuschicken kühlboxen die schafwolle die
fakten in den cola co und soßen fleisch
erkennen kann haben sie sein fleisch mal
probiert natürlich wir haben wie war das
schon gleich ein pml praktikums es hat
ja so hart gewonnen dass wir mal die
mario basler den mama war schon ein
komplettsystem kommst mit butterweichen
kartoffeln die wir hier vergessen ich
hab da weisen sich auch ins leichter im
bestell und seine alten schweine
gegessen das ist eine
fleischqualität die man überhaupt nicht
vergleichen teil mit dem zu leistenden
klassischen supermärkten gekauft haben
wir verspielt
ist schlaf wie zb wir sind keine tiere
schlachtet das ist so weil es bei den
bauern einfach toll ist dass man die
tiere denn viele händler verkauft hat
und dann ist das tier hat auf dem
laufband gekommen aber das darf und was
aus den augen lassen zumal sich
eigentlich nur dafür dass
in der gegend wann immer gesagt er ist
der erste dementieren die augen schaut
und er möchte ich noch dabei sind
existiert haben sich dort so eine kleine
schlacht uns eingerichtet die bauern aus
der umgebung kommt und sie sich selbst
schlachten auf dem mond gesehen wie er
wurde schnell bedeutet und dann
ausbluten lässt und er versucht sie eine
stressfreie schlachtung zu machen und
hat mir das gezeigt wie ein tier dessen
ausgeschlachtet wird unter den zehn
größten planeten und nicht selbst
gesehen hat wie
die fleischqualität wird wenn das
schwestermodell schießen und all diese
dinge ist sogar bedenken sind
beizubringen hat sich geschlagen selber
beigebracht hat über youtube
kanäle beigebracht wie man schweine
zerlegt und vermarktet das selbst und
das macht mittlerweile vierte boll
greift sie haben gerade schon angedeutet
dass es ein hochgradig gefährdete
mikrokosmos so ein hof man hört ja auch
das versprechen lautet schafft ihr mehr
tiere an erweitert ein hof dann kannst
du mithalten im konkurrenzkampf und dann
soll aber einen schnitzel nicht teurer
sein als ein schokoriegel und plötzlich
kostet mineralwasser mehr als milch und
sie schildern in ihrem buch auch das
schwierige verhältnis zwischen den
bauern zwischen investoren und banken
skizzieren sie doch einmal wo darf
wesentliche probleme liegen die jemanden
wie christian bach lag an den rand des
ruins bringen ein bisschen zurückblicken
vielleicht in die
70er jahre als die landwirtschaft
kümmern
rausgekommen ist auf dieser klassischen
landwirtschaft ist noch bis
1970 in dem buch schreiben die
landwirtschaft die mein vater erlebt
habe in meinem buch mieten um mein vater
gemacht haben erzählt hat wie hat man
noch 20 jahre vor meiner geburt bin
jahrgang 19 73 also ein ganz alter waren
ziemlich jetzt noch zu den jüngeren
menschen im land mit 48 yards aber die
landwirtschaft vorzeitige geburt
weisungen nicht viel anders ist die
landwirtschaft die 19 oder vielleicht
doch im aktienjahr und sogar die bauern
haben die kartoffeln selbst im feld
gelegt umgehen mit den tieren die felder
bestellt und dann ist sehr verrannt
leben hat in die modernisierung
stattgefunden so ähnlich in den
handwerksberufen beginn des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts unterhändler haben die
fahren
sie mehr produzieren können und dann
kommt die zeit entwickeln sie haben auch
auf den weltmärkten noch einmal mit
taten müssen so am durchgang haben die
europäische gebetet zu europäischen
union der europäischen börsen noch
einmal passé auch auf den europäischen
markt und den bauern hat man eigentlich
den bauern meiner generation und ihren
eltern hat man eigentlich in den
landschaftsschutz zu seinen botschaften
gegeben nämlich mehr
nicht wächst wird über bleiben werde ich
mit der zeit geht geht mit der zeit
größter schatz denn jeder
österreichische bauern auswendig kann
und der zweite ist du musst dich tun mit
der zeit zu gehen verschulden und immer
mehr mehr
erhalten weil mir die markante geld
verdienen und die dritte erkenntnis war
es ist eigentlich nicht so wichtig der
helm konsumenten zu kennen sondern
liefert der eine ware ab der bauer
liefert ab er liefert der verkauft nicht
sondern eher das lagerhaus macht es sinn
und die genossenschaften machen das sind
und der baustelle noch keine rechnung
sondern er bekommt das geld dann bezahlt
und man hat hier noch so auch eine
sprache
ist so anwandlungen an dieser
eigenschaft den baumschnitt die
produzenten sind die konsumenten
konsumenten kennen lernen sowie des bei
uns zu gast beim wählen bei den
weinbauern der fall ist die kennen alle
ihre kunden die wissen genau was relativ
wurde sondern man hat sie dazu
angehalten weil ich viel zu produzieren
so das ist die globale kulisse der
beruflich einfach leer steht und auch
bachs vater und auch erzählt dann noch
vor 20 jahren ganz klar so wie alle
größeren stall wochen mehr für wir
brauchen mehr lang und wir müssen die
investieren wir müssen kredite aufnehmen
und da kommen jetzt die raiffeisenbanken
ins spiel die er ursprünglich
genossenschaften der bauern war für
verarmte bauern wo die bahn zusammen
können wir wieder die helfen anderen
klaffen tiefe expansionen sehr gerne
reduziert weil sie natürlich sehr wenig
risiko ecke dabei wie genossenschaften
an dem die banken liefen sie können mit
ihren krediten in die grundbücher der
bauern die bauern haben sehr viele
gondelboden sie haben vielleicht nicht
sehr viel geld in der kasse und die free
cashflow am konditoren und dieser grund
proben der wird nicht weniger wert in
solchen regionen und daher mal gedanken
auch sehr groß bereit diese kredite
abend da zu finanzieren was will es gut
gegangen bevor sehr viel da ist es eben
nicht gut gegangen zu bauen beginnen zu
verkaufen wir die betriebsmittel zu
verkaufen und selbst wenn ich gerade ein
die bauern ruiniert und die mussten sie
aufgeben oder der werksbahn werden die
landwirtschaft grobi werden unter
bachler dem ist genau das passiert das
eben sehr viel kredit aufgenommen hat
und das beklagt dass ich auch gar nicht
dass ich zum opfer sei oder dass das
irgendwie die schule anderer war sondern
er hat das getan
hat nämlich nicht imitieren also
möglichst viele flächen möglichst große
und dann kamen zwei entwicklungen
nämlich einerseits eine änderung des
fertig mit dem zudem bauen wir auf
einmal begreifen müssen dass die
geförderten fläche auf den almen zu
kleiner gerechnet wurden weil zum
beispiel
krabbeltiere die grafen nicht mehr in
mitgerechnet wurden bei zum beispiel
leere liefen auf den fruchtbaren
gras nächsten das verschaffte gießen die
winter auch dazu führt dass das boden
nicht wegrutschten erwähnen dass das
nicht mehr gefährdet ist dieses war das
ist oder viele andere dinge wenn muren
abgegangen sind dann ist das gestein ist
und oben nach unten gerutscht ist aber
wenn man nicht förderungswürdig gewesen
und damit forderungen verloren dann
kamen die milch noch einmal die chinesen
nicht mehr bekommen haben europäische
milch zu trinken da kann man nicht preis
nach unten gerasselt dann kam für ihn
gesundheitlich einfach der ist in der
schweren der durchsuchung geraten er
wollte sich eigentlich in bringen immer
wieder hat mit dem gitarre gespielt und
diese faktoren zusammen um dazu geführt
dass er eigentlich seine kredite nicht
mehr bezahlen konnte und immer mehr und
mehr in die schuldenfalle gerutscht ist
bis zum schluss allerdings zählt ein
dozent
htc verletzt für eine konkurrenz bis zu
14 prozent gezahlt und irgendwann kam
dann eine nachricht dass es zu ende ist
und dass eben versteigert davon haben
sie erfahren und daraufhin haben sie
eine crowd funding kampagne organisiert
und es ist unglaublich mehr als 12.000
menschen haben daran teilgenommen und es
kamen über
400.000 euro zusammen der hof war damit
gerettet aber wie erklären sie sich dass
in relativ kurzer zeit so eine enorme
summe zusammengekommen ist
die große
politische fragen dieses alter eben auch
eine fallhöhe bekommen und zu einer case
der geburt müssen nicht ich habe damit
eben von einem nachbarn einen wirklich
weiter mit meinem sohn ein nachbar hat
neben geschrieben und der ruf steht zur
versteigerung aus und ich hab dann nicht
auf der website wo versteckte mich kunst
gemacht werden durch diesen hof
geschickt und habe meine augen nicht
getraut dass diese wunderschöne hof mit
den tieren um 500.000 euro
ausrufungspreis sind gemeindesaals und
moser versteigert werden sollen und wer
die gegend kennt weiß dass sich sicher
die bahn abgesprochen hätten und er
hätte mehr als 100.000 geboten sondern
bereits gekauft und dann hätte man sich
halt die
ersteigerte ware
aufgeteilt
hier müssen wir müssen irgendwie
wir müssen schauen dass du das geld
irgendwie hat nur gesagt na jahr
bewerben vielleicht durch spenden 30 40
50 tausend drang organisieren und was
war wieder ein feines grund zu kaufen
müssen sondern dass es gegen die schulen
ihre finanzplanung 26 erbe befreit und
dann kam eben diese unglaubliche spenden
studiert stellt sich die frage was
führte zu 12.000 menschen den
achtungspfiff wächst um mehr als 4 mit
dort aus spenden ich denke dass er nicht
weil sie irgendeinen bergbauern hessen
wollen so ich glaube dass die leute
erkannt haben anhand der geschichte von
bachler es bachler hier auch für einen
reform geistig das ist jemand da ist der
eine anderswo an formen umgang mit der
kreatur mit einer tour mit auch mit der
öffentlichkeit will der bauern
entsprechend repräsentiert hat das ist
immer dies der sicherlich sind chance
mal abgewiesen hat auch gegen die
politik der diese die falle in die
bauern geraten finden immer mehr
schulden zu machen immer weniger für die
produkte zu bekommen für das spiel hart
zu arbeiten aber dafür eigentlich her zu
leben wie man es sich im die
nicht mehr vorstellen könnte und ich
glaube das hat bei vielen leuten einfach
einen eine solidarität 6 uhr ausgelöst
und womöglich kann man auch einige gute
technische tools gehabt das duo pedro
ist der müll der leicht möglich ist
verschwendung und auch viel klavier
spielen und das hat dazu geführt dass
diese bis 1000 leute lauter mito
beiträge gespendet hat bislang 10 oder
20 euro teils sogar aus man nur im
parcours und spender und die haben den
ball irgendwie freigeschlagen ich glaube
das ist auch ein protestler gegen die
panthers und bank moser die diesen bauen
eigentlich keine andere alternative
anbieten konnte durch wollen brauchen
wir gar nicht moralisch jetzt seien es
geht ja jetzt weniger um eine
rock-geschichte die banken haben auch
ihre bedingungen haben wir in basel
verstimmungen diese einhalten müssen die
keine lehren zu schenken weil es auch
gezeigt dass es hier sondern eine
politische momentum gibt dass leute
sagen wir wollen für juden mit den
basler am leben halten und das ist
passiert
wie hat christian bachner das selbst
erlebt und empfunden
ach ja am anfang nicht überzeugt davon
geld anzubieten müller gefragt ob der
power der und spenden bittet er ist
eigentlich ist wirklich drohte in einem
ort der wahl welcher hat mir selbst
gegenüber nicht getrübt haben dass wir
die nacht unheimlich zu geschwister das
sagen wir haben sagte journalisten
gesehen und städte aus wie in der später
3000 follower hat kann sich
verschlechtern
dem steht das sagen dann kommt das in
bewegung was sie auch gestimmt hat wir
haben wir dann wirklich auch sein team
aufgestiegen pr leuten viele experten
die das auch abgeklopft haben ob
zivilisation auch wir gefühl macht und
ob dahinter nicht vielleicht im wie
damals schulden stecken muss mir ja
leben und wer war das erste mal und dann
haben wir uns auf zwei dinge die reinigt
nämlich einerseits ist auch etwas geben
muss wenn es auch land verkaufen er kann
nicht nur von den spenden leben das er
musste einen beitrag leisten weil er ja
auch selbst fehler gemacht hat und es
hat auch nie verhehlt nämlich im komisch
betriebswirtschaftlich einfach falsch
kalkuliert um das zweite war dass mir
und da habe ich ihn wirklich gewundert
dass er gesagt hat man die schulden zu
sagen durch die spenden gedeckt sind und
breda diesem pool zu er will dann auch
keine leiter entspannt machen damit er
hätte ja dass ich auch zum beispiel der
volksmusiker andreas gabalier da bin der
erlebt hat in der spendenaktion ziele
auf einmal pro stunde ungefähr 10.000
die viel konto geschlossen das sieht man
vor zehn tagen pro stunde und er hat
dann eben warum wir diesen bereich von
defekt zum schluss aus ich bleibe diesem
tool zu ich will keine spenden wäre wenn
ich will aus dieser not nicht jetzt zu
seinen reichtum in dem sinne verschaffen
dass ich das ganze irgendwie
abzuklatschen und das hat nicht schon
sehr schwer beeindruckt wer von uns
würde das tun wenn sie die möglichkeit
haben jede stunde 10.000 dollar geld
zustecken zu bekommen das ist ein anfang
so reicht das will ich nicht das nämlich
nicht
und ich glaube da sind dass letztlich
auch die erde direkt hat ihn zu einem
tor viele leute dort sind die nicht
wohlgesonnen war zu zahlen das ist als
spinner da oben machte bergen aber viele
bewohnen auch umgekehrt dafür dass er
irgendwo zuzusagen medien und gewisse
widerborstigkeit auch wenn die
durchzieht und das mittlerweile
erfolgreich hoffe deal auch für die
zukunft erfolgen
sie schildern in ihrem buch den fall
bachler sie interviewen aber auch ihren
vater sie schreiben rezepte auf mal sind
sie der nüchterne journalist der zahlen
referiert dann wieder kommentieren sie
als teilnehmender beobachter warum haben
sie so viele register miteinander in
schwingung gebracht
nicht durch google nicht kenne
nachrichtenagentur plattform ist ein
persönliches buch habe ich versucht die
verschiedenen jahrzehnten auch wenn wir
wollen auch in diesem literarischen
reportage zu bedienen
um eben dieses buch dass er ein sehr
kurzes buch nichts zu suchen 60 seiten
aber ich wollte einen gewissen rhythmus
ich habe begonnen zuerst wirklich
klassisch mit einer reportage
wir fahren und wirklich so
aber dann natürlich begonnen und damit
gewicht dieses schicksal auch persönlich
erreicht so zu sagen was warum warum
beschäftigt mich das persönlich und darf
ich dann im schnitt gemacht auch auch
dass die listig und die therapie
selbstständig kurzen kapitel wo ich der
reporter genau sind geht zu meinem vater
machen mit ihm ein interview so wie ich
normalerweise
politiker liegen würde und interview man
erfährt also übernehmen denn gemacht und
mit ihm ein gespräch gemacht gegen die
bayern gefährden wollen wir es halten
zählen lassen wie hat man eigentlich in
einem dorf was ist eigentlich an das
gewesene fünfziger jahren als ist noch
schlagen straßen gab unter vermehrt mit
der vater dinge die er mir nie erzählt
hat nicht dass das eine erkenntnis ja
auch tage gemeinschaft zu haben das
nicht das so fasziniert hat war dass das
ein bild davon weder heimat zwar noch
romantische typ sondern er muss einen
ort gemeinsam sowie geschrieben wo alles
passiert ist kommt bis zum totschlag von
liebschaften kegelabenden maskenbällen
tipps zu - und dass die eigentlich das
dorf angelegt für die zwar weder
besonders romantisch macht besonders
brutal das ist ja auch etwas grünen
bereich immer wieder wir haben ja sowie
klassischen das durch ein heimatroman
vom rostocker und und dann an die hand
die heimat romane denken sie ein peter
gewinne und dafür mehr und ein für mich
dann der anruf dort zum vorschein
nämlich eine welt der kinder sehr
vielfältiger fachmann und das war das
erste und das zweite weise beschrieben
und war eben gewählt dass die hat man
gegessen wie hat man tiere wie hat man
sie geschlachtet und das ist nicht so
dass man regieren zu viel respekt
entgegen gebracht hätte aber eine frau
zu schlafen war ein tages ereignis das
so genannte short hat es geheißen du
bist doch viel zu fahren die kommen
unkritisches den ganzen park zulegt und
nachher als delikatessen gehabt und da
gerne mein vater hat der ac die als kind
mit einer bluetooth empfänger in die
schule gegangen ist und jeder wollte
abreißen weil er selbst einmal mit etwas
ganz ganz besonderes war und da reden
wir von den fünfziger der reden wir von
einer zeit die ganz schnell vorbei war
wohl sehr schnell durch das studieren
die dorfstraßen das gefühl des
fernsehers durch die durch den
supermarkt dadurch dass die dörfler aus
bendorf sehr leicht gehen konnten dass
die arbeitsplätze außerhalb des dorfes
ist diese dürfen die gesellschaft zu
fallen das möchte ich wieder romantisch
und geschlagen groß bejubelt das ist
auch passiert also diese art von
lebensformen
und
jetzt eine andere lebensform abgelöst
worden hier war auch eine andere
lebensform war in der produktion sondern
auch und gedörrt die bauern dafür die
badenden ich glaube 50 bar angegeben in
diesem 150 ehre
und das sind im wesentlichen
verschwunden und ich bin doch nicht und
ich gefahren bin wie ich einen anderen
wagen besucht nicht allein
schweinebauern der massentierhaltung
macht heute und da sieht man einfach wie
sich in 30 40 50 jahren die art wie wir
mit zb mit schweren um die bekannte kg
das hat unterstützung für mich auch
augen und wenn ich vorher eigentlich nie
wieder wachsen die haltungsschäden der
halle waren das immer wie geschehen hat
dieser baut er sagt ja auch sie zitieren
dass wir bauern hinken der
gesellschaftlichen entwicklung hinterher
was haben sie denn da alles beobachtet
in diesem betrieb
betrieblichen geworden durch ein video
von tierschützern das ist ja in
österreich gegen deutschland so der
tierschützer auch so für alle medien
mittlerweile verstärkt nutzen und auch
technik nutzen und tierschutz
mittlerweile ja oft dass praktikanten zu
bauen und gehen oder zu ihm zu
schweinemastbetrieben länder nicht mehr
wirklich bauern gegangen die
fleischproduzenten aber vielleicht
industrielle und dort auch
knopfbatterien knopf kameras
installieren dann sogar mehrere wochen
verlegen geprägt finden können diese
tierschützer aussage video material
gefunden oder unser produziert wo man
sie die bauern tiefe eine ohne betäubung
kastriert sie ohne betäubung in
geschwenda abschneiden wie sie zum teil
geschlagen werden bewegen mit toren für
voll mit es für einen die geboren werden
die eigentlich erzeugt stürmers in
geeste entschied sich wehren sich auf
gewisse außer betrieb wer aber
eigentlich passwort oder gestalten ist
für viele viele betriebe in österreich
das ist nicht deine freunde dreht
gewesen sondern sich so wie die schweine
halten was mir
ins auge gestochen eine war dass dieser
betrieb nicht mehr in einem dorf setzen
und hoffen am acker warum steht das
wahnsinnig stinkt weil dort nur mehr
ammoniak freigesetzt wird weil die
kleine dort nicht mehr auf stroh leben
oder draußen herum
schnüffeln obwohl genug platz für die
felder für diesen großen geschichten
voll spaltenböden hallen in denen es in
lähmende gestimmt man muss sich auch so
gut anzüge anziehen weil diese tiere
auch dass in den ersten kammern oder
einkommen diesen zuchtbetrieben auch
gegen viren resistent sind und es stimmt
schon dass es ihnen wirklich die idee
die tränen aus den augen zeitungen sie
dort in diesen tonböden spaltenböden die
schweine stehen die die ganze zeit wurde
hier das ist ein geblättert
eingefressen den ganzen tag eine
mischung aus getreide und soja sowie ein
computer programmiert und diese tiere
sind eigentlich fräsmaschinen und wenn
man mit ihm spricht über diese das sind
zwar wie man es schwer eines und das
pferd uns schon eine hoch intelligente
tiere sind intelligentes runde dass sie
ein ritual haben wir 17 20 mal stärker
ist das verbunden und sie müssen damit
der schwarze auf dem vollspann
bodenständige experimente schließen und
man sieht den sogenannten sucht eben
eine wirklich als auch die nur dazu
dient durch den stall zu laufen um den
ganz eigenwillig schwein nicht wieder
breite für die besuchte da würde wieder
weg gesperrt dann hat man den eindruck
das ist 1000 m großes rechtliches
unrechtes diesen schwer angetan wird und
man wird die 100 200 500 jahren auf
diese art und tierproduktion schauen und
sich denken was haben die menschen damit
den vielen gemacht und warum zu welchem
preis und diese power mit dem ich dann
sehr lange gesprochen habe er hat nicht
zugelassen und hat mich abend eingeladen
das dann ab verstoßen und erzieherin den
sehr lange zugesprochen das erzählt dass
sein vater wird die hälfte der schweine
hatten die gesten gewinn zu machen und
dass er die kleine menge verdoppeln
musste und dass er eigentlich im jahr
würde mir ungefähr 30.000 euro gewinn
macht mit dieser schweinezucht obwohl
100 brauchen wir euro investieren muss
sowohl diese die fittiche highlights aus
der eine million euro bezahlt hat und
diese kredite an die reifen zurück
stoppen muss ähnlich habe ich das gefühl
die hat auch keine große lust mehr hatte
diese form von sprays produktion zu
betreiben und er hat sich ein zweites
standbein aufgestellt nämlich bekommen
um zu züchten hin welt und hat
mittlerweile mit diesem berg machte den
gleichen wenn man den mitteleinsatz um
den gewinn hat das siegreiche
gewinne die das schweinezucht nur mit
einer völlig anderen belastenden welt
und da steht man bei dem diesen allem
praktiker kann auf dauer
funktionieren da muss entdecken hatte
dieser teil der recherche letztlich
auswirkungen auf ihre
ernährungsgewohnheiten
ich sage ja so ich bin ich bin leider
noch weit davon entfernt denn wie gebt
euer kapital zu werden aber ich
versuche zumindest die 99 prozent der
fälle kein konventionelles schweiz jetzt
mal zu kaufen ich muss gestehen dass mir
wirklich
der appetit nach dieser aktion fly fehlt
ich habe einen anderen wagen buchen
computerjournalist zugleich spielbar der
vergleich
die sich für eine damit im november mit
über zwei millionen menschen in einem
keller sperren wohl nur kompliziert wie
würden in die ganze zeit nur irgendeine
form von 13 füttern diese menschen ist
die ganze zeit fressen würden mit seiner
nase immer noch seine experimente
einatmen und
koordinieren die frische luft würde sich
nie bewegt und dann essen wir diesen
menschen wie andere dieser wie anders
mutet es schon wenn er irgendwie dieses
lebewesen es brauch ist eine gesunde art
sei es zu produzieren nicht nur ungesund
wie das tier ungesund für das ökosystem
rundherum das sind ja unter warum diese
schweine haben die gemeinden oder boden
mit dem sie zusammen gestanzt wird
pestizide eingesetzt werden wo
das system sich
aber erst auf wenn man das meer gesehen
wird wir benötigen schweinestalls sehr
oft verträge spaß in den vg stromberg
weil wir ja durch die landschaft
zusammen sind denken ja schöne ferien
der mit weißen und mit reizen und
getreide und dahinter liegende halle
aber das ist eigentlich mit natur nichts
mehr zu tun oder sogar mit
landwirtschaft zu tun hat dass es in
wirklichkeit industrialisierung von
natur geworden ist hier insgesamt den
großen schaden ist
angeraten und das hat mich als einen
ignoranten der mit dieser welt nie was
zu tun hatte die tierschützer es gibt
sie zu
wenn der staat schulden für ihre aktion
gemacht haben gesagt ja okay die tiere
die schon eine gute hand aber wenn man
das aus der nähe beobachten lässt
womöglich in eine argumentation pfeile
und das bestreben ist zwar zu zeigen
dass die menschen vor gar nicht allzu
langer zeit noch anders gelebt habe und
wir sind die rezepte meiner großmutter
angesprochen habe zuge der recherchen
das kochbuch meiner großmutter gefunden
und was mir dabei aufgefallen ist eine
wunderbare kirche wird keine rolle wo
ich mir aufgefallen ist dass in dem
kochbuch fast keine speisen mit
fleischwaren sowie unglaubliche
kreativität
im umgang mit mehlspeisen mit gemüsen
mit allen dingen aber fleisch war
eigentlich die aufnahme mein vater
erzählt meine suppe gekocht dann hat man
sich vom nachbarn der taugen geholt und
wir hatten eine super eingelebt und den
hohen das war schon etwas besonderes
aber diese alltäglichen von fleisch die
beständige in der einschätzung von
billigen müssten und geschnitten das ist
einfach erst in den letzten drei vier
jahrzehnten in dieser weise passiert und
wird dort und in frage stellen ob es zum
gesünderen menschen macht unter und
umgebung geführt
es wird zu ihrem buch auch einen film
geben verraten sie uns noch zum schluss
was uns da erwartet
der in werde im april in die kinos
kommen bauern bogen sowie das buch es
ist eine dokumentation und kurt langbein
der nicht und gerichte das leben
begleitet hat der sich im groben zügen
dem buch anlehnt aber vor allem die welt
von bass latin schwester das schöne ist
dass kiste wasser deines herzens eine
rolle spielt weil ein wahrer guter 10 1
also wenn auch die zuhörer dieses boot
kraft einen eindruck bekommen wir wollen
wir hat auf der facebook-seite der
hauptberuf krakow liedern aber das ist
eigentlich ein kalter nicht wachsen
sondern weniger umschlag kommen wenn ihr
dann findet man eben nur facebook seiner
seite und man kann das eintauchen in die
welt ist es sehr sehr
eigensinnigen eigenwilligen aber auch
sehr verwischen erwecken und gefilmt
geben die welt ist den baslern finance
behalten und gleichzeitig mann bist du
die welt ist schon alles muss wird dafür
kommt dann wenn die auch zudem praktik
unterwegs ist indes schon allison sagen
der ja ähnlich in mitleidenschaft
gezogen
wie die us wirtschaft weil hier eben
auch ein paar große big player mit sehr
viel auch staatlicher kohle
produktionsweise angenommen haben darum
werde ich nicht mehr gut tut die
teilchen die sich integriert werden das
vielleicht nicht bekommen haben und so
genannten inseratenaffäre und da hat war
wird nach partnern die augen geöffnet
sagte
journalismus war eine wichtige ressource
ist wenn die wirtschaft und die offene
debatte und da an während eigentlich
getroffen um für per berufung soll
einmal zwei monaten geplant für
ausgewählte beiden welten bauer und bobo
wie aus mut freundschaft wurde ist im
zeuner verlag erschienen und kostet 20
euro
vielen dank florian klenk
in den schoß und auf unserer seite
faz.net / bücher - podcast bücher mit
finden sie weiterführende hinweise wenn
sie fragen oder anmerkungen haben können
sie mir gerne schreiben die
e-mail-adresse lautet bücher - podcast
faz.de bücher mit sie können unseren
podcast auch abonieren leiten und ihn
mit sternchen auszeichnen vielen dank
fürs zuhören und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]